nice andrew houston welcome to the show
thanks atlas
glad to be here
so pumped
non-dual devotion
such an exciting topic
yeah yeah
it's beautiful
something that you get to talk about
quite often yeah so
yep yeah
yep
we both do
exactly yeah
one could even
go as far as to say that it's
sort of the last
question that is asked you know what's
the nature of reality
and then when you find the answer the
question dissolves has that been your
experience as well
yeah yeah it has i i
didn't really come into this from
a spiritual seeking a conscious kind of
spiritual seeking
uh
path in the same in the same way as many
do
uh definitely
you know an ex-existential
crisis sort of uh situation and
the uh
the sense of
not really knowing
who i was and
what this world was and
in an unconscious way attempting to
reconcile the discrepancies between
what seemed to be my identity and
and the
the presentation of the world
and here it was really an expression of
grace that allowed for a deep
surrender
into just the immediacy of
of this is-ness
that was
just given to whatever uh
whatever needed to unfold in order for
there to be
peace in order for there to be
contentment
and then the inquiry sort of came a
little bit later surrounding the nature
of identity but it was always more
in
in my case what seemed to be a
relationship with god at first
and in that relationship with god
essentially just saying
uh
i belong to you
and
you live through me
and you speak through me and this life
isn't
isn't mine anymore it's yours
and it was through that process that
you know the sense of a
limited
individual
as a substantial identity
was transcended and
i came to see myself as this infinity
[Music]
ah
but that wasn't you know
taken on as a
as a methodology or or
an attempt to move from one place to
another it was
it was really optionless in the context
of
the perspective here there was no other
no other choice because
life as what seemed to be this this
separate individual had become so
unbearable
so i could not
continue
in that condition
[Laughter]
life became unbearable as a separate
individual i could no longer continue in
that condition
yeah and and when i say that condition
it's it's more like
the sense of being the one that is
that's in control and making decisions
uh
you know for for a short while even
after there was field recognition here
there still is a sense of being andrew
but
andrew wasn't andrews anymore so it was
like andrew belonged to divinity and
andrew was a servant of divinity and
andrew was being
guided by divinity so it wasn't andrew's
life anymore so that was like the
initial
uh
step into a deeper recognition of
reality
recognizing that it wasn't my life and i
wasn't here from for me
and as as what seemed to be
andrew and
that i was here to
to be given
to this higher truth
and to be led and guided and directed by
by this truth
in in the way that
is
known to be fit in the immediacy of this
of this is-ness
quite interesting
that it wasn't a
conscious spiritual seeking
for you
so
there was an
unbearableness of
the individual condition
and
there was a
there was a seeking of healing that
unbearable
to
through this divinity through this grace
through this surrender through this
recognizing of is-ness
yeah it was
you know just to give a kind of a brief
recap
in early childhood things were
um very very beautiful and very very
connected and
there was uh there wasn't a sense of
being localized in the in the same way
as there was uh
in in the teenage years so there was
like a sense of expansive sort of
diffuse
ness but i didn't have any
um
you know anything to compare it to so
you don't really know that it's there uh
until it seems to go away and if you
don't even
uh understand what that is then there's
no articulation for it and uh
so around the like in between the the
ages of 7 and 12 years old
uh an intense qualitative shift began to
take place in my experience so
from that interconnected sort of diffuse
kind of
um
not as localized state uh where things
were kind of just seen as a game and
play in this world wasn't taken
seriously and and things were just uh
they were different
there was a dropping into an intensely
acute sense of separation and locality
where
the the sense of being
inside of the body as like a sort of
almost like a
um
an unwanted uncomfortable
prison of sorts of course i'm speaking
about it retrospectively
began to begin to become very very
prominent and uh in in that condition
there was a demand for attention
in in a different way so
it couldn't be
ignored the sense of being
so separate and so limited and so bodily
you know
couldn't couldn't be ignored
and uh so that's when seeking began to
to
to express itself but it was seeking
through
attempts to find you know relief in in
phenomena and uh whether it was like
watching tv or
eating
macaroni and cheese or
um getting uh getting other
uh
kids to laugh you know at school or
whatever the case may be there are there
are lots of different ways in which this
uh
sense of separation attempts to fill the
the uh
the void that
seems to um
you know separate it from from what
appears to be the objective world
and that developed into
uh substance abuse you know
in its own way and that became
what it became that that became equated
with with existence yeah
and uh so for about
10 years solid that was all that life
was
and uh
substance there wasn't
yeah yeah substance yeah for 10 years
yeah yeah yeah so
um
wow
yeah by the time i was 24 i'd been an
inpatient detox uh 15 times 7 to 21 days
at a time five longer term treatment
centers
in and out of county jail
uh
it was just a shell
of us
kind of like a skeleton like you know
humanoid um
walking about and in a condition of
hopelessness
and and a deep sense of uh fragmentation
from from life
so in that sense i wasn't you know
consciously seeking
uh enlightenment or anything of that
nature
i i had never heard of
the word enlightenment until
after i already had
field recognition
so
interesting and you've been using that
word which we can circle back to maybe
you can give us a brief sentence when
you say field recognition you mean
is-ness you mean god's presence
yes i do i mean the presence of uh
divinity yes as as uh conscious
awareness particularly the feminine what
i refer to as the feminine aspect of
conscious awareness conscious presence
and
field recognition in the way that i'm
using it here does not mean field
realization it just means that
there's a recognition that there's not
empty space here that there's a field
and
at that point there still seemed to be
andrew that was aware of the field right
so
there is still a sense of
a limited identity
um but there was the recognition of this
field as the presence of god
yeah
and so
how many years uh for you um was it
after the 10 years of so that was 24
until like 34. or up until 24 was 10. up
until 24 yeah so it was like 14 14 yeah
14 to 24
uh of
you know just
and and that's that's not the whole
story it's it's everything you know from
um
just the
really the uh
sort of the bottom of the human
condition looking in relationships
looking in substances looking
uh just looking out there
for
what can't be found out there yeah
and uh
perfect
and and wandering blindly
and and uh
you know feeling like there was a sense
of knowing what was going on but being
completely asleep too too
the truth
yeah because it was really based in a
lie so it was
living a lie
and
at uh at the age of 24
i left a uh
an eight-week program
and a week after leaving i blacked out
behind the wheel of a car going 45 miles
per hour and hit another car head-on
and all three of us ended up in the icu
on life support
and i came to in a hospital with two
tubes coming out of my chest both lungs
had collapsed and
ruptured artery lacerated spleen liver
shattered left
tibia crushed right ankle
whoa
yeah you're you're almost dead for sure
oh yeah yeah they called my they called
my grandparents and said we're gonna try
to save him but you know so it was like
a kind of a you know
i was a a rag doll the body was really
beaten up and uh
and the other the other two had some
serious injuries to their
to their pelvises and legs
and
so
after i was able to be taken to jail i
was taken to jail
and i was in a medical isolation jail
cell
in
the spartanburg county jail
and it was in that jail cell that this
grace
revealed itself
i was approached by a man
who was in
a 12-step program
and uh he basically came in and sat down
beside me and said
you know andrew
your problem isn't
alcohol it's not drugs
your problem is that you're selfish and
self-centered
oh interesting
yeah
whoa and i had i you know i had read
that and and heard it because that's
definitely you know in in any case of
addiction the
the root of the addiction is always
going to be the sense of separation and
the sense of separation is always
rooted in egocentricity yeah perfect
that's so you got a direct pointing at
the root
that's great
and it's interesting because there's so
much of
cultural
dynamics that are in the
in the branches in a sense trying to
find
what
what what is it about my addiction or
what is it about my
um
obsession with relationships or seeking
to travel or whatever it is that people
want to fill um
but it can't be found there because it's
actually
in the root and what's at the root is
the sense of self lowercase s and its
focus on itself um
and that egocentricity like you said and
you got pointed at it and and then like
the shift is then the service to others
shift
and then that can be
so
instrumental in awakening is redirecting
attention in service yeah uh outwardly
to to other selves that's perfect
yes
yeah that's exactly it so although i had
heard that before and you know
intellectually understood it it had
never really penetrated the heart so
the conditions were appropriate for
that to penetrate the heart and
he left and as he was leaving i
sort of whimpered to him
because i had a neck brace on and was
sort of you know in kind of a pitiful
you know feeling sorry
feeling sorry for
for andrew
and i was i was like come back
and he was like i will
so
i don't remember exactly what happened
after that but when whenever waking
consciousness returned
i
recognized that there was
um
like a clear translucent
uh
field
presence
in in the jail cell
and everything was different uh
the
you know the the cell itself was like
new
in a certain way
and
not as
doom and gloom as it seemed to be before
and i had this knowingness that came
that everything was
unfolding according to plan
yeah
and
some
some specific
teachings of jesus christ also came to
me as well
and then from that point you know
truth became more important than life
itself
and it was that initial shift from
you know thinking about andrew to
thinking about how i can serve
others
even when there still seemed to be the
the sense of being andrew yeah and
really that was you know
uh service to god so service to god
service to others same because there's
only one yeah oneself yeah
and uh
a little bit about the mc the mechanics
of that uh
the the egocentricity
is actually a constit a concealed
condition of infinite subjectivity so
we are actually
the the the center of
the universe yeah
um but not as a limited individual
entity yeah we're the
we're the supreme self yeah yeah and so
everything is self-referential
everything is referential to the self
totally everything is uh
the self experiencing itself but this
self that we are is a field of conscious
awareness it's the light of
divinity
so it's not a it's not a body it's not a
mind it is an infinite mind if you will
but it's not a limited mind it's not a
separate individual so
there's a concealment of this
subjectivity this infinite subjectivity
within itself
and there appears to be a concealed
presentation of a subject which is
referential to objects and what seems to
be other subjects
so that egocentricity
um
has within itself you know certain uh
limitations and uh
an inability to discover uh an abiding
peace and contentment because it's based
in a
in a concealment of peace and
contentment
perpetual
perpetual lack and perpetual um
asleepness to the is-ness
yes yes asleepness to the is-ness
exactly
so when
there is a transition from that
egocentricity into
the recognition of ourself as this
as this silence as this
vibrant life that's all around right
here
then what's taking place is that there's
a revealment of subjectivity within
itself so it's moving from what appears
to be a concealed condition
into a revealed condition and an
intermediate sort of phase in that
is where there's a transition from
the concealed condition appearing to be
uh
consumed with its concealed sense of
identity yet to beginning to look to how
it can serve what appear to be the other
subjects
within its perception
and that's actually the one subjectivity
serving itself
uh although it might appear to be
you know someone serving another and it
will appear to be that way uh initially
but what's revealed is that all service
is self-service with a capital s
absolutely
whoa i love you bro
i feel sweet
i feel so aligned together this is great
this is so good
wow yeah
yeah i'm i'm really grateful that um
i feel i think it was one of the um
people that views both of our content
suggested this and i'm really grateful
to them um this was a really good one
yeah i feel
i and we're we're just you know whatever
20 minutes in and i'm already um
in love with you this is great
he's great
love you wow okay
brother wow
so
what what else interests me about this
isn't is not only like the
as jung and so many others have said
that you know you go all the way down to
these roots of hell in order for these
flowers to blossom um
especially the ones that reach all the
way up as high as [ __ ] mountains
and that's what i'm feeling from you a
lot is i mean you did not have
like a classical
oh um i wanna you know seek
type uh
experience
um
no bro you got hit by a train
like you got hit by a train like 10
years of addiction to substances the
blackout behind the car with
two or three other three other people in
the car were with you no i was the only
one in in in in my car and then there
were two in the car that was hit another
car okay jeez yeah so three of you total
three total went into icu
um your body's like a ragdoll um
you're blessed with this turn from
the self-referentialness
which this is
this is my next um line of
um conversation with you which is how
did you
find
the um nomenclature the lexicon this
vocabulary and this way to also talk
about it because
um you speak about it perfectly and it's
really rarely when i've encountered
people that know how to speak about it
so well and so what did you do from 24
um until now are you 34 now
no no i'm
well i was just joking yesterday about
how i can't remember how old i am so
yeah
i think i'm 30
yeah maybe 31 i think i'm 30 yeah cool
so nice dude yeah it's the that that
facial hair adds a couple years you know
yeah yeah yeah but i can see the
youthfulness for sure underneath yeah
nice so i'm i'm 28 so we're right around
the same age and so what happened those
six seven years um how you picked up
the ability to speak about it
like what did you look at you mentioned
christ um we talked about before we went
live that's avalokiteshvara there so you
do seems to have some buddhist and hindu
also um
insight so yeah so how did because you
spoke about it so perfectly the turn
from the self-referential to then the
service to others turn being what then
enables one to recognize more and more
of themselves as the one as it all as
the dance of of the one's light
yes yes
yeah uh
so before we get into that i think i'd
just like to say one more thing about
the
what we talked about thus far
and that's that a shift in identity is
not brought about through suffering
so sometimes if someone hears um this
the story of of andrew
as a as kind of a linear you know
a very small fraction of of
of a linear uh
expression of what seemed to happen
there can be an interpretation that it
was through great suffering that there
was like a break in the in the
psychological structure or something
like that that's not what happened at
all and there are many many many many
many human beings who suffer very very
very very intensely even more so than
what seemed to take place here and they
do not have awakenings they do not have
shifts right
so
the a shift in identity is an expression
of grace it doesn't come about through
suffering
and what i've described is like i said
just a sliver
it's only a speck in in the broader
uh trajectory and non-linearity of of
the truth of our self as this field so
uh
cool and that kind of that kind of leads
us into the the languaging piece which
is that you know there's no there's no
accidents so um i don't consider that
car wreck an accident and uh actually
the
the other two that were involved in it
had also
um been through the same treatment
center that i had just uh
that i had just graduated from
and
um
so they were also
they had also went through addiction
they had also passed through that yeah
and interestingly enough um you know
the way that it all unfolded i i
recognized in the in the in the jail
cell to be an expression of perfection
and
i know that that is hard to believe and
it's really beyond belief so i wouldn't
expect anybody to believe it
um
but that
that is the case and
of course the the other two guys uh
are really wonderful and we've all you
know uh
hugged and told each other we love each
other and i've spent time with both of
them and and those kinds of things
as a part of the immense process that i
was involved in for
for quite some time
but when it comes to
languaging and these kinds of things
what
what really was expressing itself was an
opportunity for a total replacement yeah
or a total transmutation or
transformation
so what i tend to emphasize is a
transmutative path where
essentially that which is
commonly discarded
is used for fuel or is recognized to be
a precious valuable substance that's
just waiting to be revealed so
it kind of goes to the
uh alchemical understanding of the the
turning of base metal into gold yeah
and the symbolic representation of that
in in love
in the conscious experiencing
that's so good what is so bassy like
just oh this breath of air this moment
of presence is actually [ __ ] gold and
yeah yeah that's great bro yes yes
everything everything has the potential
to be revealed as gold because that's
the only reality the only reality is the
golden light
of the of the one brilliant dazzling sun
of our
of our pure divinity
so
uh when i got exposed to the spiritual
understanding it was like
a fish that had been flopping on a shore
for
ten years
uh being put in the water
and
i
just uh took to it in um
in really an unexplainable way
um and when i say i took to it it was it
took to itself i mean i wasn't uh you
know i had no concern with being
spiritual
um and i still don't have any concern
with being quote unquote spiritual being
seen as spiritual
uh wasn't i wasn't interested in
realization
any of that
um but just truth truth
so
because truth uh was a necessity it was
a non-optional
necessity for life yeah
yeah it was like octagon
yeah yes oxygen exactly so i realized
uh through grace that i could not live
without the truth yes
and
that initially
really
you know is referential to
what seems to what seemed to have been
um the mess of of andrew's life so
um the the the initial years were really
really focused on
going through the 12-step process in a
in a very very rigorous way
and that's a that's a very simple
process but a very profound spiritual
pathway that is oftentimes solely
associated with addictions
um but actually it's a it's a an
extremely powerful pathway for anyone
but most are not going to uh
really have the motivation to take the
12 steps because
you know it tends to uh be something
that really
brings up a lot of resistance from the
ego structure
so in going through that process um
you know uh quite rigorously
purely you know powered by by grace and
and drawn by a deep devotion and love
that was that was really the the most
characteristic thing
is that i was completely and utterly in
love with god
and
i
i mean just so in love i couldn't think
of anything else
and
it was relational at first
and it was you know very very
um intimate and
time consuming
and i mean all time you know i don't uh
didn't
everything else was accountable to that
so it wasn't something that was
compartmentalized that fit into you know
my day
i didn't have a day anymore
and
i realized that i never had a day it was
always the day of this of this one
feel but i seem to to presume that these
days were mine and that's why this life
was mine and these kinds of things
so it was really a transition into
recognizing that
um this life isn't mine and these days
are not mine and these me these hours
are not mine these minutes are not mine
uh so called you know
at least when there seemed to be
time and duration
uh
you know which there hasn't been a sense
of that for some years now
but
the
at that point that was the case and so
it was about really the surrendering of
time and the giving up of that
and
yeah it just became progressively more
consuming it was a consuming fire
and still is to this day yeah uh even
though there's nothing you know it it
just uh it's it's it's referential to
sort of
a different scope or a different
parameter
like capital s
um referential that kind of yes yes
exactly yeah yeah yes exactly existence
becomes that that's cool i like that the
shift from lowercase s self-referential
to capital s
self-referential
yes
perpetually yeah that's so good
infinity referential all day
yeah yes
yes just the field of love dancing uh
yeah like dancing
so good
that's so cool
yeah
yeah so i started to get into different
uh traditions i mean i i was raised in
the south so
uh i was raised around christianity and
and so right here in the in the bible
belt as they call it and
i
when i was first really exposed to the
teachings of jesus
i knew i knew
that there was something there
and there was a deep resonance with the
message of love and
just the whole the whole way of being
[Music]
but at the time you know it was the
ability to reflect that was very very
limited because of the the concealed
condition within conscious awareness
so that was kind of the initial step uh
in in this unfoldment was having that uh
sort of
going back into into jesus's teaching
and
and having um what could be seen as more
of a christian kind of sense of
of uh
of relational love in reference to uh
the father and and those kinds of things
and
working with the holy spirit
and uh then that began to transition
because i
you know very quickly with the
recognition field recognition that was
present
um
you know pre even pre-initial shift
there was a an understanding that
god you know a lot of what was being
presented
in religion was so far off base and
um began to explore different uh you
know different
philosophic
uh backgrounds and and different
spiritual expressions and
so that all unfolded rather quickly you
know reading the dao to ching and the
bhagavad-gita and
those kinds of things
and just getting into different
whatever kind of
spiritual text i could find
and whenever i would read read them it
was always a confirmation
of what i was seeing and what i was
knowing
rather than reading them to to
get something out of them so it was it
was almost like looking in a mirror when
i when i was reading
these different texts cool
and
that that unfolded you know
with this kind of continuous drivenness
of devotion
that was
really into
a lifestyle of inventory and
introspection
and of course that translated into
identity you know like you were asking
at the beginning what is
what is i and and what does all of this
processing seem to be referential to
this you know notion of um andrew as
separate from
these kinds of things and
uh
and
yeah that the the the field continued to
appear to brighten and become
uh more consistent more continuous
uh
cool
started to kind of
see it um like a
aura around plants and different pieces
of furniture and those kinds of things
more regularly and then that became kind
of continuous so that
the field and the
at first it appeared that the
the conscious presence was
here and then there were objects within
it and then the objects started to be
recognized as sort of permeated
by it
and that you know sort of all blended
together and there was an intense kind
of flow of love yeah
and
um a sense of kind of communion with all
of
nature and everything and i was just
sort of swept away in this kind of
um ecstatic
yeah ecstatic in in rapture
with just the love of the divinity of
everything
and that was nice yeah
and that was uh
and now you know i'm describing this now
in a
right you know currently my i don't
consider memory to
be you know anything
uh
yeah
substantial but uh it's more from like a
knowing
knowingness because even
to reference that i don't really feel
like i went through that you know um
the 13th step
no that's not the 13th step but i like
that they actually in in the program
13th step is when you try to get with uh
when you when you
when you uh when you look for a date in
the in the program in the early years
which i actually did end up dating
someone so i did i was guilty of the
of the 13th step as well
but uh we call the 13th step that
there's lowercase s self never happened
yes yes okay yeah beautiful exactly
yeah okay so that's that this was all
actually prior to that shift uh the
initial shift actually where so there
was still a sense of
andrew going through this with all the
field recognition and sense of love and
communion and everything so it's a very
relational refined kind of devotional
point
which it's always been very devotional
but more on the feminine side i would
say
in reference the way that i uh sort of
um demarcate the the the qualitative
aspects of infinity
and
then uh at a certain point after that
building building consistency getting
into meditation and those kinds of
things
uh continuousness
there was uh sitting down on the bed
one morning and the sense of a personal
separate self disappeared
so the sense of a me
disappeared and i saw that i was the
field
that i had been
seeing that i was always just seeing
myself
nice
and uh
that was the initial shift and then it
was followed by
um
different contextual modalities as i
referred to them
uh that uh you know unfolded um
over the next uh
the the following years and uh of course
continue to deepen
to this day
very cool
love it
so there's so many pieces there to pull
on
so
one of them
that i love was that
you share that there's so many
other selves that are undergoing drastic
suffering around the world but yet it is
not always um a drill sergeant for
awakening it is
it it is in many ways a drill sergeant
for awakening and it's yes it's
incredible but at the same time
apparently it's it's not oh wait it's
not as well which is very interesting
like
there can just be a sincere
drive for um understanding one's true
nature and it just be starts like
philosophical like just the love of
wisdom and
something like that
so
quite interesting and then another
thread that you that we could pull on
for a bit was that
um
and also just on that last bit it also
plays into the refresh rate of the light
as well so meaning that it's
andrew houston a moment ago that was
drastically suffering or like you
described a moment ago where yourself
you had a quote localized lowercase s
self-referential and then all of a
sudden the next moment there's the
dropping away of that and recognizing
that i have been this field this entire
time
and
and so the refresh rate there was like
and like where was the like where i
can't find the old version um
and so
that so there's that also so who was
suffering where was the suffering um
of
um play and then this other thread is
great i'm imagining right now the you
know this living space right we have
these pillows and um
and similarly where you're sitting right
now wherever you guys are are sitting um
you know take a or listening take a
take a gaze at your surroundings and
when you do just see the radiance of it
um rather than
um
what appears to be just something that's
like static and not dynamic and not um
radiant um but when you do begin seeing
it that way
there's another thing that sort of
clicks in for you which is that it's all
made of love and light and that it's
here to serve in infinity expressing
itself and exploring pure potential
and
that
then it starts coming together
more and more
um that was another great thread and
then
we mentioned this a little bit um
in the first thread that i was saying
was that it was really cool that you had
such a clear
dropping away of this lowercase s self
and to recognize yourself as as the one
and
for me it's been very similar with
processes that are both gradual and also
sudden
and
and that
um there's nothing quite like the
the sudden ones are
um
you know you can't really describe
um what it is but it's
but it's so cool because you you know
with a deep amount of conviction that
this is the process that the one goes
through that we as the one go through
you know
you know it with insane conviction
because you know that um
like you are the dance and there's no
cooler way to like dance with yourself
than to do this process of forgetting
yourself and then remembering yourself
through a veilus veiler gateless gate
it's an unbelievable feature
of the reality design
in exploring pure potential do you feel
similarly
yes yeah i'm i'm glad you brought that
up because i you know in in telling the
story quote unquote is is always uh it's
always
something that there's
um
a recognition of a need for or
disclaimers surrounding
and
and this is great because it just brings
us into
the the mechanics of of awakening and
those kinds of things and looking at
shifts in identity so when i describe
that that seeming point where there was
a
falling away of the sense of there being
an andrew that was experiencing this
presence
that in itself is like a flowering or a
culmination
but just like when a flower is blooming
it it's not that only when it opens and
and reveals its uh
the color of its interior
petals
is that it's blooming the whole process
is its blooming
so if we interpret the shift in identity
as an event that's a very very very very
limited way to look at it because it is
not an event
and of course we can say it's a
non-event or and not a non-event or
whatever
i don't want to go into all that but
it's you know it the analogy of the
flower is so good
yeah i like the flower blooming and that
that point is just you know sort of a
selection of perception and saying okay
here's where there was a seem to be a
definite recognition
that the aforementioned process wasn't
happening for someone and was actually
only a parent
yeah
and
but that's not even though i did say you
know the shift in identity i'm saying
that in in reference to what seems to be
the difference between field recognition
while there's still a sense of
uh
substantial individuality as an identity
and
you know the this field of conscious
awareness realizing itself and
recognizing itself as itself yeah but
i'm not one to place a lot of emphasis
on
that taking place like hammering away at
that it's really more as far as i'm
concerned about the devotion and the
commitment and the unfoldment and the
flowering because it's always going to
be progressive
even when there appear to be these
definite points
you know of of distinct recognition that
we can recall and speak about and
you know all of those wonderful things
that's not really what it's about and as
i said before
that wasn't being sought it was more
about the love
the love and the willingness
to give everything to just uh
yeah to be totally
absorbed by
the truth of
divinity yeah
devotion perfect
the
the blossoming
is lifelong
because over time
it becomes more and more clear when one
is
coming from
holistically the one whereas when
they're coming from a last bit of some
sort of separation conditioning some
sort of ego self-referential structure
behavior pattern
and so
um
when you have this
ongoing purification and ongoing
polarization more and more towards
devotion towards pure service to others
um
it it makes it so that it's a continuous
game it's the continuous flower
blossoming
yeah
it's nice yeah
and and there's there's actually
multiple shifts in identity so
you know that that what i just described
was just the beginning
and
we we could go into that process
surrounding different aspects of
infinity and qualitative presentations
of infinity if you want to
um one thing that's important to
recognize just around as a kind of
generality of the process
is that the residue of the illusion of
separation doesn't just disappear
because you see through the
substantiality of it yeah
the the backlog of energetic
condensation and his associated
emotional reflections and psychological
impressions and different thought
patterns is still there and it's still
there because
this was a concealed presentation of an
intelligent infinity of subjectivity so
whatever subjectivity which is the
infinite field of conscious awareness
takes itself to be seems to take on a
certain energetic validity and although
it never actually was the case in the
way that it seemed to be because it
seemed to be to you
uh then it seemed to uh take on this um
quality of accumulating certain residue
certain uh vibratory uh a certain
vibratory backlog we might say so
and this is true on a collective level
and on what seems to be more of an
individuated level which those the lines
between those of course become fainter
and fainter in in in the unfoldment of
our of our truth
but essentially one of the major aspects
of the process is going to be facing and
resolving the
unconscious energetic backlog yeah
and
that is through a process of what i call
surfacing so
even in a very stable clear
certain shift in identity there is still
going to be surfacing of the residue of
what appeared to be the previous
self-definition
and there is going to be different
contradictions that are
present the ego structure doesn't
disappear just because you see that
there is no one here
that's the identification with the ego
that is transcended and severed but not
the actual ego structure which is
present on a collective level
and
so this is the process then uh on a
daily basis of the surfacing
of the of the backlog into the field of
attention perfect so that it can be uh
faced and resolved
and
the the way in which we're able to do
that most effectively and efficiently is
to recognize
that this is one field of subjectivity
that is reflective in its nature so
everything that appears to be
unfolding has a reflective quality to it
and we begin to step out of the realm of
causality you know presuming that there
is a a cause and an effect um either
from here to what seems to be the world
out there or from the world out there to
here
and that takes us out of the realm of
victimhood and blame which are two of
the the those are primary ego positions
and extreme self-limitations
yeah
and we step into this supreme
responsibility of infinite subjectivity
yeah so we're recognizing that
really our the responsibility is here
there's nothing that is coming from what
seems to be the world outside that is
bringing about what seems to be present
here yeah and of course as we begin to
see that
what seemed to be the world outside is
actually an appearance in our own
hereness in our own field of infinite
hereness
then that translates into the to the
ease of recognizing that but there are
still the tendencies and the
proclivities that are based in the
survival oriented intelligence that we
seem to be identified with
or you know
great expanses of what appeared to be
linear time that uh are are surfacing
into the into the field of
activity surfacing into the field of
attention into the field of conscious
experiencing
so
perfect
yeah
there's a way that we can be more
effectively and efficiently aligned
with that process of
resolution which from my perspective is
just a process of transmutation so it's
essentially seeing all of that backlog
as
fuel as a precious valuable substance
that we have the opportunity to
witness being converted into the
fullness of bliss on a consistent and
regular basis and i find that
apart from devotion there's going to be
a lot of difficulty around that so
devotion is one of the primary ways that
we're able to stay with a a steady
direction
that isn't getting lost in kind of like
awakened not awakened why is this coming
up i see this and you know those kinds
of things which is you know to see those
kinds of mechanics is also very valuable
and very important too because there's
different
um
tiers to the ego structure the
superstructure there's different limited
reflections of kind of like awakened
identity realized identity that can take
place
so these these are things that as a
collective we're gonna be exploring more
and more as the
uh as things continue to unfold
yep
so cool
yeah
love uh love this so if we
if we look at it like
um
for those that are
um born that
um
if there is an uh taking in of said
separation conditioning because for many
people that are born um in
um to
more awakened parents or to potentially
some indigenous tribes that are very
interconnected with nature um there
isn't even the self-referential
structures and conditionings and
separations that even come on in the
first place okay so let's say that it
does come on full head-on and you're
like a hundred percent feeling
separation yeah so the flower blossoming
as we've been sharing can be something
like seeing over time that yeah you may
have some gradual decreases in
separation down to like 95
separation and then you may have a
sudden shift to like
um 20
um lower to like 75 separation but then
you may have some more gradual another
shift and then some more gradual and
then these last residues like you were
saying these surfacings um energetic
karmic unwindings um vasanas or some
scars as has also been said these
grooves of conditioning they're patterns
that come up in our behavior
that we have the opportunity like you
said when you basically see all of
creation
in service
to that process of going shifting from a
sleeping and separation to unwinding and
softening to no separation
to being the field
and
um that that's your honor it's your
honor it's your duty it's your joy to be
a firework of infinity um to be um the
one expressing itself through this dance
and um and i like how you use the word
devotion as like be devoted to that
entirety of process
um and know that that's what's unfolding
here and
that is just like
it's just really resonant it's really
cool
yeah beautiful
yeah love love isn't concerned with how
long um how much how many times
it is only concern with itself and the
giving of itself
so
repetition
is just a natural expression
of devotion
and commitment
and
our
what we're recognizing is that our
identity
isn't actually going through this
because our identity is with divinity
and of course there's different
recognitions of
um infinite identity
but
that the this is a process going on
within conscious awareness so it's a
process going on within the experiencing
of this field which is our light
and
when we really begin to see that all of
the material that was really being
condemned and seen as unspiritual and
pushed away and uh you know lark locked
down in the dark dungeons of the
of the unconscious
is is is a precious fuel and it has the
potential to be converted into
the light of
the blissfulness of our self
then we begin to see it in reference to
its potential to be converted rather
than in reference to what seems to be
um
kind of a
a cleanup job that has a a beginning a
middle and an end because what we're
dealing with here in in our current
collective is a is a significant backlog
of um unresolved condensation associated
emotional reflections and psychological
impressions
with correlating thought
patterns and behavioral expressions so
collectively the transmutation
is not something that
is served by us getting to a point where
we're done with our part and we're just
like we're not transmuting now we're not
there's nothing coming up now because
that's kind of like a an old idea of
awakening that comes out of a more
concealed age which we're trans we're
transitioning out of a more concealed
age so
we're we're not coming from the
extinguishment perspective in the same
way
necessarily anymore where you know
nirvana is kind of just getting to that
point where nothing is coming up and
that's what the goal is or that's what
the arrival is and that's where we're
being absurd that's where we're able to
serve from we can actually transition
our perspective to seeing that our
service can be
the uh the continuous surfacing of the
residue of the illusion of separation as
it is referential to this collective in
the direction of transmutation so the
nervous system becomes more and more
refined in its capacity to attentively
allow the energetic backlog that has
been stored and that of course is is
um
profoundly important because you know
the majority of the nervous systems on
this planetary system
are not equipped to participate in that
process so
it's really recognizing that service is
non-linear and it's not about what i'm
doing in form like i'm going here to to
you know bring you a bag of beans or
something like that that's very
beautiful and what really matters in
that is like the intention and the and
action and the and the fact that you're
willing to show up
for
this other expression of yourself in
that way and and you're you're tuning
into love and discovering that and
that's and that's a huge part
of of the unfoldment but what begins to
take place as things continue to unfold
is we recognize that what is being
healed here is being healed everywhere
so we can actually begin to recognize
this body as being infinite and there's
different
you know different degrees of that as
well and so what what begins to take
place is that all this material that's
surfacing is recognized to be a deep
opportunity for healing for the whole
for the whole of humanity
yeah
and we're just more and more in tuned
with that process and that's not
something that we're doing as a project
like oh hold on i've gotta heal humanity
real quick or you know whatever those
kinds of things no it's a it's a natural
expression of devotion and commitment
because like i said in the beginning
this isn't my life you know uh it's not
about
my story or
uh
you know where i live or what i do or
any of those kind of things yeah
it's about what the power of god what
the power of divinity is going to do
through
the appearance of this form how it's
going to demonstrate itself so that
it can see itself
yeah
so that andrew isn't seen and andrew
isn't remembered and andrew
isn't
what it's about it's about what you see
that appears to be expressing through
andrew yeah
and that's the opportunity for all of us
is to be
just swept into the flow of disgrace to
be transformed for the sake of the glory
of the reality of love so that love is
glorified
and anytime there appears to be
human weakness
all that is is just an opportunity for
divine strength and divine power to be
revealed
every single seeming human weakness is
just an opportunity for the power
of the reality
of the pure divinity of i to reveal
itself
i loved how you called it precious fuel
such a good way to put it every single
contraction every single conditioning
every little bit of separation every
little bit of karma
all of that is just precious fuel for
the unwinding and the softening
um
and the awakening it's it's precious
fuel
it can't be seen any other way when one
clearly sees all as perfection it is
precious fuel and seeing it that way is
it it
enhances and accelerates devotion as
well
when you see it as precious feel
so good
and it's not always easy to see it that
way i'm um
it's you know what what what's being
described is simple but not necessarily
easy
the
and it's not a matter of us being able
to remember that or
to say okay let me remind myself that
this is what this is
it's really that we're receiving
the grace that's leading and guiding and
directing it's showing
that the truth of ourselves as this
intelligent infinity is showing
showing us that it's precious fuel it's
showing itself
that this can be seen in this way it can
be
held in this way it can be attentively
allowed in this way
and
it's
we're showing ourselves what a what a
beautiful gift that is like what a
profound opportunity
we're sharing in together
to be joined in this common commitment
in this common devotion
and this willingness to give yeah
it's so good
and that's why this school analogy is so
strong also
so everything
everything can be seen as little
lessons
yes
and
to be
god the ultimate
student
the ultimate infinite student of
from n for endless lessons
um capital s
self-referential lessons
um
what
cooler
game could possibly exist i mean this
may be what we could play on a little
bit but when you were talking about
intelligent infinity in in terms of um
expressing itself um
perhaps beyond this dimension is that
where you were suggesting we may chat
about or what were you suggesting
earlier oh no i was just talking about
different shifts in in identity here in
in in in this physiology in in human
physiology so there's different
um recognitions of infinity there's
different qualitative recognitions of
infinity that i refer to as contextual
modalities
and essentially this has to do with
predominance of aspect
um
at least yeah initially
and uh
so i could kind of go through that a
little bit
basically there's two primary aspects to
this field of our self
which is the infinite
context for all of the seeming content
and form
that is appearing perceptually
and
these aspects can be held
from the perspective of seeing one of
them as a masculine aspect and one of
them as the feminine aspect
now when i use the terms masculine and
feminine here
it is not referential to the gender of
course there's some relationship in
translation in terms of what we consider
to be you know various qualities and
those kinds of things
and also in reference to the way in
which the physiology
uh appears but
on the level of formless subjectivity
masculinity and femininity are not
referential to
male and female they're not referential
to gender yeah
they're
the different
aspects of our self different yet
non-different they're
distinct yet inseparable so
they're not two yet there is a
definite
recognition of the distinction initially
and
the simplest way to move into this is
recognizing that there is an underlying
silent still
changeless pure awareness
pure perceiving
a simple silent seeing
and then there is a vibrant
conscious
aliveness a full
presence
of infinite knowing
so we have the aspect of silent
changeless pure awareness
the simple
seamless
still seeing
and we have the full vibrant conscious
aliveness the
presence
of pure hereness
existence itself yeah
these aspects are are not to they're
non-dual
yet they appear distinct and initially
the distinction is prominent
and there can be a play in reference to
the modality as to whether one appears
to be more or less substantial so
generally speaking the feminine aspect
conscious presence
tends to
appear negated in its substantiality in
certain modalities like pure awareness
dominance or source awareness
and
source awareness is a condition where
there's a recognition of our
identity as
the
source
of
these two aspects that i just described
so initially in source recognition the
source
is a quality-less
no thingness
and infinite thatness
that the thisness
of conscious awareness appears to be
shining from
and pure awareness is like the lineless
line
in between
the quality-less no thingness
and
the full vibrant conscious presence yeah
nice
so that's the condition of source
awareness
and that's where there appears to be a
triple layering basically so source
awareness com most often source
awareness
has a triple distinction
sort of prominence to it and then
there's a condition that i refer to
as dynamic subjectivity
dynamic subjectivity is where
the distinction between pure awareness
and conscious presence collapses
[Music]
and
there's a revelation of conscious
awareness as an infinite flowing
fullness of subjectivity
and this is where
subjectivity recognizes its own primary
vibration and pulsation
as the self-experiencing that's
appearing as all of the different
formations so you experience yourself as
a mass of
vibrating
conscious awareness this is not an
experience in space or time and
it's a continuousness that the days
appear to unfold within so it's not
something that
changes
and and
in dynamic subjectivity
there tends to be more of a refined
recognition of the mechanics of the way
in which the self-experiencing flow of
conscious awareness is appearing as form
and appearing as like time
appearing as space
appearing as
all these different things so there
tends to be more of a recognition of the
intelligence of the of the light
uh in the way that it sort of reflects
and projects within itself
and
dynamic subjectivity here was
post-source awareness
and then there is a condition
that i refer to as the void or supreme
nothingness and that's where
um
the
field of conscious awareness
seems to be rendered insubstantial it
seems to fall away entirely
so even from a perspective of source
awareness that would mean that the
triple layering appears to fall away
entirely
and awareness and conscious presence
seem to disappear or are rendered as
insubstantial
apparitional
non-light so it moves from like a light
value to a non-light value
and light here
would you say that this is what would be
said in as nirvana
uh it depends i mean i've seen initial
shift just like no self referred to as
nirvana i've seen nirvana used in many
modalities like different modalities so
there's there's a there's a great over
generalization on on earth surrounding
uh you know conditions of infinity and
and those kinds of things
um that just is
characteristic of a more concealed age
which we're right now sort of in in the
midst of moving out of a concealed age
so the way that awakening and shifts are
held
historically as far as we're concerned
because we only have like a small sliver
of history you know where these things
are spoken about is is referential more
to cons to a concealed understanding of
the process that has kind of um
you know various
connotations surrounding uh
liberation kind of escape you know those
kinds of things and and
different you know that's a whole huge
subject
okay so another way to maybe mention
what you were just mentioning would be
cessation
cessation yes yes so the the any kind of
negation term is is appropriate uh in in
that context but it could also be used
in reference to the recognition of there
not being like um
a conceptual world so oftentimes in the
initial shift what takes place
is uh
there's an emptying out phase where
basically everything that was deemed to
be like an independent object with an
associated label and and the sense of it
being that is kind of uh
rendered uh
uh
void of meaning value and significance
but that's different from the void that
i'm talking about uh that i just
mentioned because that's referential to
actual
full
light value realization and there not
being any objectivity but the actual
disappearance of subjectivity seeming
disappearance of course subjectivity
can't really disappear but it seems to
in supreme nothingness
so
in initial shift there is a a very
distinct phase that
many are going through currently
that is characterized by negation of the
sense of
things being their mental definition
so it's like you used to think this was
a tv he used to think this was a chair
he used to think that was a door those
kinds of things and it was like that's
what that was and then as you become
more and more naked
in in the immediacy of
what's here those labels and things are
kind of like revealed to be just words
they don't act that's not what it is
so this is where you may hear a lot of
like just this kind of like only this
this you know it's not the it's not the
word it's not the labels not the concept
so
yeah the immediatism yeah yes yeah so
it's kind of like a um i consider it an
initial kind of stage
uh that of course is most prominent you
know on our on our planet right now so
just to briefly um recap just so that um
i feel like we're all following along um
we're talking about like a palette of
different flavors of infinity
recognition you could say or um nature
recognition
yes you could say that yes um it's it it
i mean i would say maybe that the
palette
um
analogy is going to be more
referential to like traditional flavor
of the way in which each modality is
held now
each modality there there are certain
traditions that tend to emphasize
certain modalities so
classically or typically one moment
andrew could you also then um clarify
what um
what colors on the palette or what
flavors that you've covered so far for
us as well okay so well i kind of did a
brief overview but i'll just go back and
kind of restart so the
um
again because you've mentioned there was
one that had um it was like source um
recognition which is
source awareness it was like a three
there was a like a three layered
recognition of infinity with
the prominence of identity leaning
towards the source so it's it's a
basically a progressive recognition of
one's identity as being the the most
fundamental recognition of infinity and
of course the light is infinite but then
you see that you're the you're the
source of the light and those kinds of
things so
perfect okay so there's one that's one
that's source awareness but before that
in the initial shift it's referential to
light value realization so that's either
going to be in the aspect of pure
awareness or conscious presence as a
predominance now very often there's a
recognition of both aspects but one of
them seems to be a predominant sense of
identity yourself i agree with that i've
seen that before quite a bit okay so
interesting this is fascinating so these
are like um higher level distinctions of
um different flavors or characteristics
of awakening which is really interesting
so
i've seen that split actually quite a
bit between pure awareness and conscious
presence
quite a bit and then that's where
identity gets like intertwined in that
style of awakening or flavor of
awakening and then so then there's that
color um conscious presence pure
awareness you could say are either one
color or two separate colors can be um
viewed that way and then there's this
you said it's a um source awareness is
it's awareness the triple layering yeah
so what are the and then where where
were you
dynamic subjectivity is what i was
describing as an infinite flowing field
of subjectivity
where the self-experiencing of conscious
awareness uh within itself it reveals
the different
mechanics and dynamics of the nature of
creation so you experience
yourself as
flowing creation yourself as flowing as
creation
and everything and there's different
characteristics which i have a
modalities course on on the website
where i go at two hours on each modality
uh pretty intricately it's it's older so
there's a lot more i would add to it now
and i'm not saying that it's complete
but it continues to be filled in
um links in the bio below for those that
are interested on the non-dual hyphen
devotion.com website
thank you okay so so that was that was
um
dynamic subject dynamic subjectivity yes
dynamic subjectivity that was for
supreme nothingness yeah or the void um
okay so
and is this the end or is there more no
there's more yes then there's pure
divinity
uh and purity
that's the last one okay it's actually
the first one um but it's also the last
so pure divinity is the
is the fundamental truth of i right
and
um
pure divinity is infinite love infinite
glory infinite sacredness
uh
infinite uh exquisiteness
infinite uh these are descriptive you
know ex expressions they're not
uh in opposition to there's no op
there's no position
yeah um
just in the realm of language so yeah
and that's prior to to nothingness or
nothingness yeah
and
that is uh
characteristically different from
supreme nothingness
supreme nothingness is like is fl is
flatter it's infinite peace yeah
but the presence of an exquisite love
that's completely non-linear and
totally
um
interesting melting of any kind of
vibratory distinctions yeah is not there
so but of course love is being revealed
all the way through
but pure divinity is
almost like
if we were going to look at it
descriptively in terms of color which
can be helpful sometimes visually all
right source awareness which is a triple
layering
is where like infinite black kind of
infinite tv screen you know um
is begins to shine forth and and then
the sort of glass on the screen is like
the
conscious presence pure awareness sort
of light we might say yeah
and pure divinity is where you realize
your reality as almost the the golden
source of even what appeared to be the
infinite
black totality
yeah
interesting so you have um this the
sixth one is called divinity or pure
divinity
so then you
um in the source awareness example which
i think is also very common um very
common yeah
um
so you say pure divinity is a golden
source
that then
is is is the um substratum of all of
those pallets
correct yes
dope bro
but each each one is going to feel
complete and it's going to feel like
that's the substratum so in source
awareness
you're quite sure that the quality list
no thingness is this is the substratum
is the source
and if someone were to hear me from
source awareness and they were kind of
closed and not open then they might say
you know no he's talking about what
happened before this is the reality but
that's a confusion of levels uh
of modalities that's not each one feels
subjectively like it's it
because it's subjectivity right
and it's also infinity so you say how
could there be more infinity than
infinity
but uh that's what you said before when
it was just a light value and then you
recognize that it's
more infinite
it's not a matter of more or less you
see what i'm saying because it's kind of
like a limited interpretation
their distinctions
um
that i feel like are um
for advanced adepts um i feel like
they're really relevant um for advanced
adepts for those that are sort of um
already quite field realized and have
also already tasted multiple palettes um
colors on the palette um that this can
be helpful like it's quite helpful right
now for me and i love your golden source
example i actually really feel that um
as something that um
it's almost like the
it's like the snitch in harry potter
uh in a sentence
yeah a little ball yeah
and then this and the seeker
fly yeah flies find that um because it
it kind of reminds me of that
golden source which also is the sun in
many ways
all of the suns um
endless suns forever and ever and ever
with endless um sentience um
on these rocks
and
that that that um
literally
golden sourceness of pure divinity is it
like that
um which is great
yeah it's interesting um because in
source awareness
it appears as if the light is coming out
of no light
non-light
so there's a paradox there that actually
is a doorway into a a deeper recognition
of reality because it feels like
it seems like
the the conscious presence pure
awareness the the radiance of
subjectivity is coming out of an uh
quality-less infinity of no thingness
that's an infinite totality
of
thatness
that's prior
prior to
this
and
that's what it seems like
right
and in that condition it is like that
i'm not saying that it isn't in that
condition but
what you can also realize is that
actually
there's a source
to that
quality list no thingness
and that that's what i actually refer to
as the primary appearance
or the primary absence with a capital a
so i have different presentations on
youtube where i go through the the way
in which divinity appears as
uh creation and then also that
you know translates into the its return
seeming return movement which is really
just a shedding of the the different
self definitions of itself so
it is only inherent to subjectivity to
seek to identify itself
and so it identifies itself as itself as
for at first as conscious awareness and
identifies itself as the source of
conscious awareness and equalityless no
thickness status
then conscious awareness itself seems to
disappear you know and there's
variations in the way that this unfolds
potentially and it's not going to unfold
for everyone and it doesn't it's not
important to because it's not what i'm
describing is not
better or worse or more or less it
doesn't have anything to do with that
and of course
any interpretation of it like that is
going to prove to be you know to show up
as some difficulty
um in the experiencing because it's
interpreting it from a very limited
perspective
there's
we're all here for the same glory okay
the same glory and the same love
it's not about these you know i i have a
certain responsibility i feel to share
these things but it's not about that you
know
it's about the devotion
you know
it's not about the modalities
yeah
um but then again we also have you know
certain cases that are very interested
in these kinds of things yeah we're
drawn to it
and uh and it becomes increasingly
relevant
in a planetary system where
initial shifts are becoming more and
more common
yeah
and
and even in and beyond initial shifts
are becoming more and more common yeah
so you know contextualization is just
it's just a means of support
uh
but it has it's it's definitely open for
misinterpretation
and and uh
can be taken on in a way that's not not
as helpful
so
that's why i always emphasize devotion
first love first because
i wasn't
interested in any mortalities or
anything you know like that that wasn't
the whole that wasn't the point of it of
course i did
begin to be drawn to different um higher
descriptions of infinity and those
things but not
not on the basis of attainment yeah
it's out of a love for truth
a love for truth
yep
yeah
it's probably one of the most important
things to share which is that
there
everything that we just mentioned that
is on the pallet is both
um
important to create distinctions or as
has been talked about like levels of
consciousness or levels of perception
levels of awakening or levels of
awareness densities of love light um
that those are really important because
in a sense they help share with you
oh i'm feeling ego i'm feeling
self-referential i'm feeling separation
well now to shift more into conscious
presence or pure awareness and then to
be in service to others and to be
vigilant of the conditioning surfacing
and this type of stuff these are very
very important
um but at the same time everything that
we mentioned about these levels and
about these colors on the palette all
this type stuff simultaneously is also
just us using vibrations in language um
in symbol exchange to create some sort
of um
distinctions so so to to to to be able
to hold that simultaneously is going to
be um you know one of the highest
realizations one of the highest
integrations so
um i i always highly encourage um and
suggest that um
contemplative um aspect to it
yeah yes
yeah it's not uh of course
we don't get very far by attempting to
figure anything out and it's really more
about showing up and being shown
so it's like uh
when our heart is is committed to truth
and we're aligned with love and we and
we really just want to be wherever it is
that we're going to be of the highest
service and we want to be wherever this
infinity wants us to be
then
we're not
easily going to be lost in you know
trying to categorize categorize
distinctions and
and um figure things out and all of
those
uh
different uh
mental mental gyrations you know it's
it's
it's not about that it's really about
god it's really about love it's really
about
truth for the sake of god love and truth
and which are synonymous in the way that
i'm using them here
and we can really feel that we can
really know that beyond a shadow of a
doubt
and
we're here to support each other to lift
each other up
and
to
um
you know sort of
bring contrast to one another within the
realm of actualizing
our highest potential which is always
the same
we always have the same highest
potential yeah
nice
yep
yeah and tuning into that on a
really simple level like we were saying
is seeing everything like a school i'm
showing up to that with a loving um
open-hearted mindset so good
and then
and then also just
you know out of
you know pure potentiality is is the
actualization of said infinite potential
and we are the actualization of set
infinite potential and
um
when you look around you and you see
um
like what it why does this you know
collective feel like it has
um so many ways that it's
also like a sleep um to its nature
and um how to you know actualize that
latent potential it's sleeping lions
um there's no sheep it's just sleeping
lions
and so
how do you activate that stylus that
each individuation is a painter in the
painting
i is the painter and that how to
activate the full list potential of the
painter in the painting process
and that has a lot to do with um
meeting basic needs on a planetary level
having decentralization
on the planetary
banking monetary infrastructure as well
as on the
planetary energy infrastructure so
having abundance for all um and full
creative will and choice and
actualization it's just
it just feels so like this is what's
happening like 2020s 2030s
and like to polarize towards that
intentionality is is it
yeah
beautiful
beautiful
yeah
wow holy [ __ ] what a profound round one
together
so cool
[Music]
do you feel complete
yeah
that's another thing that's important to
recognize is that
what we're really talking about is is is
realizing that we're complete yet in
process in process yet complete so what
seems to be contradictory is actually
complementary and and inseparable
so there appears to be this play of
process
and more and more the process
includes the recognition of what is
complete and not in process yet appears
to be in process
it is forever already whole and
so it goes like that you know
and uh
when it's not my process or your process
it's our process and it's this process
then we're diving into the to the
seamlessness of
of seeing that we we are each other i am
you
you are me
and um
this is what uh this is what it's all
about
yeah i
loved using uh perfection perfecting
also yes
yeah
beautiful it's so nice so nice yeah even
intelligent infinity is on a journey to
actualize its infinite potentiality it's
so good
beautiful so good so good
andrew wow
so cool round one complete you feel good
about intention complete yeah yeah yeah
everything feels great
yeah me too wow
yeah i'm really like rocked um by this
it feels really strong um
it's really exciting it feels like our
our higher selves our energies are are
clicking for also for for more
exploration which i'm really excited
about
yeah
i feel the same way i'm really uh
grateful that
you uh you have me on today thank you so
much
yeah and what a cool
um
what a cool expression you are nondual
devotion so beautiful i love it
so
yeah bro hell yeah
check out uh everyone check out this um
link in the bio
so this is
um
andrew's website it's
nondualhyphendevotion.com
and then
you can find
andrew mentioned that his courses are
available here
so you can find those
you can find much more of this content
here highly recommend checking it out
and then
also this is his youtube channel the
link is also in the bio below
um
[Music]
and so you can find a lot more of
andrew's content here as well
and
would also encourage you if you did find
this
conversation to be
[Music]
insightful valuable
we would love for you to the video to
help the algorithm
also subscribe to the channel yet if you
haven't
and leave a comment below with your
thoughts with your residents on the
conversation on the episode we would
love to hear from you
and
again um head over there to andrew's
channel subscribe there check out some
of this content share it if it resonates
also share this video with other people
if it resonates as well
um
and we'll collectively ignite this
awakening baby
that is all
yeah
all glory to pure divinity
all you all glory to pure divinity
brother yes all glory
all glory
all right let's let's end the stream um
but you and i will stay in the studio
okay
thank you bye everyone we love you
thank you